[Applause]
criticisms I feel like I need to watch
it again because the first time imma
literally just kind of like scared
watching the [ __ ] thing like this
yeah Jordans a killer that's gonna jump
through the screen yeah and it's just so
intense and like I've been waiting for
this for so long yeah and so I didn't
like grab on to any real criticism yeah
that I have what was yours um I don't
like that it jumps around in time line
the time I think actually yeah that was
a little bit annoying don't like the
time line thing now I can understand it
because I know what happened and I
existed during these times if you don't
know Jordan like my girl has no [ __ ]
clue what's going on right with 97 91
like these people aren't really aging so
you can't really tell based on how they
look like I could you maybe I look at
Jordans hair and I go okay doesn't have
hair I do think though for a documentary
you kind of need to draw people in with
over winning and then go back and forth
I think like the OJ timeline I think I
don't think it went chronologic in my
opinion nope also open my other biggest
criticism and they tie together is I
don't give a [ __ ] about the Bulls I
don't give a [ __ ] about any other player
I don't give a [ __ ] about Scottie I
don't give a [ __ ] about Paxson I don't
give a [ __ ] about Bill Weddington I
don't give a [ __ ] about none of these
[ __ ] right I don't care about
Rodman story I don't care about any of
their [ __ ] stories well I want it i
bi I feel a little bit bamboozled I
don't want a bulls documentary
documentary I thought it was Jordan doc
everybody's calling it the Jordan yeah
yeah I did - I did we called it the
Jordan doc he's all over it right
Jordan agreed on the footage Jordan
Jordan Jordan right what I want is the
life work of Michael Jordan I want you
to start and I don't care if it's 40
episodes I want you to start in college
and I want you to take me from college
to the final season don't talk about the
Wizards but I want you to take me to
that final [ __ ] shot that he hits
just seal it game six
yeah Game six against the Jazz give me
that and also we forget because the shot
is soap like prolific iconic yeah he
ripped crawl Malone of course and then
dribbled it down the court hit the game
of course absolutely like the D he also
made the defensive play it was LeBron
the block and the
who's the stop Amazon yeah that's why
he's the goat because he's both of you
yeah yeah well like the fact that I
gotta listen to a storyline about Dennis
Rock don't get me wrong it's gonna be
entertaining it's gonna be great but for
me I want a box set of Michael Jordan
that I could handsome my kid and go hey
this is the greatest player of all time
if you want to know why it's just pop
that in watch this for about 40 hours
and you'll get a good idea of what's
going on I hope Jordan in 15-20 years
what a nice guy we're talking is about
is the greatest I hope it just says you
know what let's just talk about me in my
life for 20 episodes now I want you all
to understand what's going on here cuz I
could really give a [ __ ] about the Bulls
GM and present like those things can be
story lines within the Jordans story but
I don't care about Jerry Reinsdorf or
Jerry Krause and his stupid [ __ ] and I I
don't care about at all right what I do
care about is Michael [ __ ] Jordan and
these other people can intersect his
life but let me just follow this Jordan
story let me if you will talk about the
season where he averaged 37 points look
I need just that remember he averaged 37
[ __ ] points yeah I need cover I need
only that what what is happening in the
league what are people saying around the
world what a team saying as they're
playing him you averaged 37 points a
[ __ ] game if you don't give me
something on just that season I'm gonna
be upset mmm Jordan hasn't been super
transparent I knew this is a Bulls
documentary going and I thought they
actually did a good job of making it 50%
about Jordan like the Scottie Pippen
back story is five minutes yeah let's
get the [ __ ] out of here Jordan we just
keep going back to it back to it back to
it I think they do a good job of saying
hey we followed the whole team with
cameras the whole team there's a lot of
drama
no but it's about this guy no one cares
about your whole team everything else is
b.b line but they make the a line Jordan
yes I think it's fine one thing I do
want to know I want to know the
transition from Jordan as a rookie who
doesn't smoke doesn't drink doesn't know
what to do in this situation doesn't go
out country kid to the maniacal [ __ ]
killer who will excess and gamble and
drink and [ __ ] everybody I'm curious to
know what that F what that evolution was
and if it was necessary for him to be
great because part of me thinks it might
be yeah he just needed to blow
love steam and there's like his Tim
Grover he's trying to wrote a book and
he talks about how like all these guys
have a dark side and you got to tap into
that dark side to be great
Tiger Jordan like the greatest of the
great have a dark side and they tap into
it and I'm psychologically curious about
that and like what is that
transformation to walk me like walk me
through what you're thinking at each
stage is your like like did you
gradually get it like out drink a little
bit off go out a lot I want to see it
too because it's seven years later in 92
he's a savage dude they're men's
gambling he's drinking he's [ __ ]
comer the Olympics oh man he's like I
don't have a guy never sleeps we go out
we party all night and then he just
comes in [ __ ] shows up early to
practice like I don't get it
yeah and I'm carries a no bad shift cuz
he seems like the sweetest kid yeah the
letter he wrote his mom is adorable yeah
just a [ __ ] hey mom God will bless
you I love you yeah just like a [ __ ]
and he's still the best player in the
country yeah
[Applause]